cette combinaison est pleine de symboles
elle ne protège pas que ta petite
personne elle protège l'univers tout
entier très capitaine l'éclair Luc
jamais vers l'infini et au-delà
du périmètre de sécurité
merci
tout le monde à la maison
je suis Buzz l'éclair je suis toujours
sûr de ce que je fais
journal de bord Buzz l'éclair après une
année complète coincée sur cette planète
l'heure est venue de réparer mon erreur
bonjour buzz je m'appelle Sox ma mission
c'est de t'aider et je ne renonce jamais
à ma mission je ne suis pas de ce qui
abandonnent non plus parfait veux-tu un
gâteau glacé pour rattraper le temps
perdu
nous devons achever la mission à qui
parles-tu
enfin ici il y a des risques
si tu es absolument terrifiant je
regrette de t'avoir accompagné
et quoi j'espère que vous êtes prêts à
passer à l'action parce que c'est un
pilote qui nous manque encore il
faudrait détruire le vaisseau alien
j'ai un plan et j'ai une équipe
formation en maniement d'armes vous êtes
donc des routier
vers l'infini vous me demandez de tirer
sur votre doigt
mets ton casque c'est plus prudent
le plus monstrueux
rien ne peut m'arrêter moi je peux si tu
continues de crier
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce bruit arrête tu vas casser
mon chat
tu aimes ça j'adore